let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's start today with our
caller from the 5 5 9 area code caller
from 559 who's this where are you
calling from
hi David this is Mike from Fresno
California okay my good one
what's going on well number one I
thought that was excellent
it's going to be great watching Sam
cedar donk on Dave Rubin more yes thank
you I appreciate that the video is going
strong well I did have one topic on my
mind that I wanted to discuss with you I
grew up as a Republican with Republican
values he went to college saw how the
Republicans busted up their surplus
after Clinton and saw how hypocritical
they were and I became more of a
libertarian
and over the time I I've evolved and
becoming a fairly strong progressive but
there's one idea that's a holdover and
it's one thing I can't get over tis no
one and the progressive what's the world
blogosphere really talks about it and
that would be the inheritance tax okay
so what's your feeling about it well I
find it interesting that any other topic
where we discussed the flat tax
progressives view it as being somehow
unfair but when it gets to the
inheritance tax they're totally fine
with the 50% flex tax as long as it's
for people over oh with my family it was
over four million dollars right well
that's the whole point it's not actually
a flat tax it's a progressive tax
because it kicks in only at higher
income or wealth levels so it's just
it's not a flat tax it's flat beyond a
certain point but that exists also I
mean even with a progressive wage tax at
a certain point it does become flat
right like for and if you want to set
the highest bracket at a million dollars
and at that point it's 50% it's a flat
50% tax on everything above a million
dollars so it's really no different I
think it might be just like a semantic
issue that you're experiencing um well
I'm wondering if it wouldn't be better
off using a bracketed tax structure like
with our federal income taxes where
perhaps people at a lower level only
have to give the government maybe ten
percent sure yeah I mean listen
or there's no question that we could do
it in a different way it would be a
matter of looking at you know if in
total it's making it more regressive I
would be against it but there are other
ways where you could do a bracketed
estate tax that I would be completely
fine with I I don't disagree with that
in principle it would just matter what
the brackets are and what are the tax
rates absolutely that sounds like more
of an Elizabeth Warren policy wonk are
you sort of topic though yes it is which
I love by the way I think it's great
that she's actually doing the Wong curry
and people seem to be liking it I agree
I agree I'm really looking forward to
the debate but I feel like I probably
taken enough of your shows time so preps
I'll call back again and I'm not just oh
all right thanks Mike appreciate the
phone call very great to hear on Mike
from Fresno very very good